as the political crisis in Venezuela
deepens the State Department is ordering
all non-essential u.s. personnel out of
the country Venezuela Venezuelan
president Nicolas Maduro fighting to
stay in power severed ties with the
United States he's upset president Trump
endorsed an opposition leader as interim
president Maduro claims the u.s. wants
to install its own unconstitutional
government in Venezuela and well the
hircus is in a new cúcuta colombia along
the border with Venezuela
Menten Manuel good morning good morning
Venezuela is in the midst of a
humanitarian and economic crisis since
2015 more than two million people have
fled the country many of them coming
through ports of entry like this one you
can typically tell who they are by the
amount of luggage that they have now
opposition leader Juan Y though wants to
change that but first he wants president
Nicolas Maduro out one day after
swearing in himself as president one way
though said he would consider granting
amnesty to Nicolas Maduro if he helps
return the country to democracy but he
also called Maduro a dictator
responsible for the recent deaths of
protesters this week an estimated 14
people have died in mostly anti Maduro
protests once Latin America's richest
country oil accounts for 98 percent of
Venezuela's exports when the price of
oil plummeted the economy took a
nosedive sending the country into crisis
under mother those policies inflation
has skyrocketed it's expected to hit 10
million percent this year we were in the
region in 2017 and witnessed thousands
of Venezuelans crossing into Colombia
daily in search of food medicine and
work and to flee violence the time for
debate is done the regime of former
President Nicolas Maduro is illegitimate
US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo said
Thursday the u.s. supports the
opposition and pledged 20 million
dollars in humanitarian aid but at the
Venezuelan Supreme Court Maduro accused
president trump of staging a coup let
there be no doubt that donald trump and
all his madness believes himself to be
the
world's police he said to put on
pressure the u.s. is now considering
sanctions on Venezuela oil exports
Venezuela is the fourth largest supplier
of crude oil to the US and sanctions
could lead to a rise in gas prices
anything but all options are on the
table I think it's a huge mistake Raul I
know Jose Ojeda is a UCLA professor of
Latin American Studies and has observed
elections in Venezuela
he says US intervention could escalate
the violence when the United States gets
involved in these types of conflicts
I've really polarized in the situation
even more making the risk of bloodshed
even even stronger there's an estimated
70 to 80 Americans working for the u.s.
in Venezuela Senator Marco Rubio has
promised swift consequences if they are
harmed Maduro has ordered the Venezuelan
embassy and consulates in the u.s. to
close but what doe has encouraged those
workers to stay put Nora it's a big
story Manuel Bojorquez in Colombia thank
you